Hello Freak bitches.
Oh yeah,
definitely got a consequence champ.
Hottovy how about your boy?
Johnny Hendricks was like,
I figured it out.
I'm good.
Andrew Jackson's.
Let me try this out.
[inaudible] son.
Yeah,
he fought the fucking eraser.
Dude.
That guy's scary.
Even Post Usada scary up hold up race or listen to me right now.
That golden snitches.
Good.
You better.
I don't know what,
although did all these years being figured out,
we got to figure it out.
I looked at his body,
I thought,
what the fuck did he so jack,
he's jacked in shape.
Goodluck might be the best looking dude in the UFC.
Yes,
we can do it on the planet.
He's right.
I didn't want to come off as gay when his shirt off in particular,
that's not,
you can get pictures too aggressive there.
Well they're doing the post fight showdown.
I'm like,
I bet he slangs all the ring card girls if you want it to.
As he was talking,
I'm like,
this dude is just slaying dick out.
Look at it right there when he was standing next to John Shit or sent the way.
And so I was like,
no Johnny,
I'm not a middle weight.
This is,
this is a metal weight.
This is a big middle man.
He's so look how much bigger he is in Johnny.
I mean,
and she's Schrag Shush.
And the fight was basically an assault.
It was an assault.
You would never believe that Johnny Hendricks was a former world champion of you
saw the way the eraser beat the shit out of him.
I mean,
he just beat the shit out of him.
Johnny fire back.
I mean,
he's tough.
He tried through some leg kicks,
threw some punches,
but he was just getting fucking destroyed and just walked down and smashed,
kick to the body over and over again.
He was wincing after the first kick.
I know,
man.
His second kick to the body,
he got hit with you see him wincing and here is when he clipped Johnny
Hendricks.
I mean it was no contest.
Unfortunately for Johnny and out of the White,
if you,
if you weren't a famous linkedin,
they're like,
oh he got,
he got out of the crowd to fight this dime piece.
Like look at that,
right?
Oh this guy who likes to drink bears fighting this diet piece,
Brazilian well might be the best league in Brazilian of all time.
By the way,
Johnny is just not the same guy.
He's just not the same guy.
And you could speculate all day.
There's reasons why,
you know what I'm saying?
Like I think sometimes people hate on guys for what they've done lately,
but for Johnny Hendricks,
I mean you've had a great career brother.
It's just hard,
a great career.
But watching in a weight class above I agree should be,
I agree cause he doesn't want to watch his diet.
I think it's a number of things.
But you know,
I just,
man,
there's nothing to hang your head on.
You got to your world champion man.
You know a lot of people think you beat GSP.
Like you've had a great fucking career man.
A lot of people.
And now a good argument to that could really,
you could really have a real,
I mean if you were just objective,
he didn't have a dog in the fight,
you could have a real interesting conversation about who won that function
argument there.
And I,
and I think if you're John and you know,
and he's probably taking a lot abuse online and I wish you would stop,
but it's all good man.
You've had a good go.
I hope he doesn't take abuse.
Really what we should do,
we should be praising heaps on Paulo Kosta.
Cause that,
that guy's scary.
He's fucking terrifying.
That guy's the future.
He's,
he's a legit fuck around.
But yeah.
Well who knows.
I and I would like to see someone test him.
I'd like to see him again.
So like a real strong hundred 85 pound wrestler.
He's four known Yosia and all knockouts or three and all knocked out his last
two.
He merch dude.
So what we got to see his,
he's for real and he's the future.
How's he now on the cover of Gq or some shit?
I'm telling you,
man,
I'm fucking,
when I was watching,
I was like,
fuck.
Well that could be the one thing that doesn't man Weinstein next to him.
I mean,
good looking dude,
man.
Maybe that could be,
what does a man,
he just,
Oh,
just young pussy.
When you're that good looking,
it's probably,
it's gotta be hard.
It's got to be hard to say no super hard and as he gets more and more famous,
you know he's going to be famous.
For sure.
It keeps smashing people that way.
Looking that way.
Smashing people that way.
That's trial.
Both son,
if he's not famous,
he should sue the UFC.
You'll look at this,
this shit.
Fuck him on the front.
Cover the WII video game for Guthy.
Useless fucks.
It just,
Johnny looked two weight classes lighter than him.
Johnny looked like he was a welter weight and the eraser looked like he was a
light.
Have Johnny's just lost men and like going to Jackson's.
I'm not knocking Jackson Jackson,
one of the greatest capital all the time still is.
But when fighters go there because they've seen how much success they've had,
it's literally heaven's waiting room.
It's,
it's the fucking,
you know,
it's the Florida of fighting cancer.
The cancer.
Yeah,
here's the solution.
But if you're going,
that's probably not the answer.
What's also got to think of the years that he wasn't there and those play a
factor in its development.
It's not like you just get right back to where he should have been like,
oh,
here's the answer.
No,
you're,
we're training wrong for all these years.
And its performance dwindled pretty substantially except for the one fight with
Hector Lombard that's,
which is really interesting.
That was like the one fight where he actually looked pretty good.
Yeah,
he did.
And he beat Lombard,
who's still fucking dangerous.
And I was like,
well,
Johnny Hendricks,
who's like,
he's back.
And that wasn't that long ago.
Hell no,
it was last year.
But there's another guy who shouldn't be at 185 pounds.
So he fought a guy who's like him,
a thick dude who's really a one 70 that doesn't have the best diet in the world.
You know,
and I don't care what anybody says,
you know that you shouldn't be criticizing him.
He shouldn't,
you know,
you don't walk a mile in his shoes and you know,
maybe his body doesn't want to respond to cutting down to one 70 anymore.
Stop.
Just be honest.
And I'm a Johnny Hendrix Fan.
Look at his body.
You should not be fighting the best professional fighters in the world unless
you're a heavyweight and you have a body like that with all that extra body fat
that does you no good.
It's not aiding your performance in any way,
shape or form.
It is 100% a sign of a lack of either planning.
We didn't plan your died out in advance where you're too heavy or too much body
fat coming into camp or poor discipline or poor organization of your diet where
you don't understand like what foods you should and shouldn't be eating.
When a guy's training for a three round fucking fight at the top of the heap in
the UFC middleweight division,
you've got to think this guy's got to be doing some goddamn rigorous shit.
The American public,
if they're watching this going,
if this fucking guy can't look good,
how am I going to look good?
And I'm not,
I'm kind of exaggerating.
He's Johnny didn't look terrible,
but like I think it was worse cause holding look great coastal elite,
like it didn't make it worse.
Statue.
And we don't all have to look like a bodybuilder with some of the toughest guys
like Evan Dunham.
He doesn't have a bodybuilder physique,
but he's not,
he doesn't have any extra weight on them.
That extra weight is not doing you any good.
The boys not willing in any events,
you know,
bodybuilding event,
but he doesn't have a fucking extra pound on them.
You know northern is Woodley Willie's fucking shredded.
He's got the best body in the division.
Woodley could wind Olympia,
he could when Mr Alleles top five just generally just got into it 100% he's got
phenomenal genetics,
but anyway he's not,
you can't be competing at the highest levels of the sport given up that much of
an advance.
Like if that was a good agreement that you had like all right,
we could fight and one 85 but you have to be 20% body fat and I could be 10 like
what?
Especially this day and age,
like mixed martial arts is such a high level.
I was just going over the,
the welterweights the other day and I'm like,
Holy Shit,
Holy Shit.
There's so much talent like the UFC in the welterweight division,
such good hands.
There's so much young killing talent.
If you're not taking every advantage of the the techniques and you're training
your had left in the dust and Jonny is from that old school kind of training.
You know what I'm saying?
Like he's an older cat man.
Well what he was talking about when he was talking about training in Texas that
he couldn't spar hard with people or they wouldn't come back,
that he had to like take it light on them.
And then what he really loved about going to Jackson's,
he was dealing with a real high level fighters all the time.
So he's getting great training in,
which I fought,
was great to hear,
but it's not great that he spent so much time doing it the other way.
Well no,
in 2017 you lose your,
you lose your focus,
you lose the drive and you just start going through the motions if you're not
being challenged all the time.
And he was obviously being challenged in competition,
but he should have been with a real camp a long time ago.
The great,
what happened with him,
he had some,
he was with team take down and they had some sort of a dual degree,
ma'am.
So he was a team take down,
he came from Oklahoma state,
right,
national champion,
whatever,
70 time,
all American,
just a monster.
And then the deal was is there going to support him financially with a house
food training camp.
They take care of all that.
They give you like a salary salary,
but once you make it work,
we're taking 50% of everything and when you're young up and coming hungry
fighter like that's a great deal.
Until you become Johnny Hendricks and become the world champion,
like hold up 50% I appreciate what you guys did for him to be like,
God damn man.
Like you're robbing me blind here.
This is crazy.
So he had to go separate ways.
Here's the question.
They open big rig steakhouse did Dave,
that was a terrible idea.
I would eat there though.
Did the,
I would eat there just for the story.
That should be getting selfie smile.
Hold off the menu,
but I'll hate on it if it wasn't good.
Johnny,
he's leave a Yelp review pro.
Have you ever Yelp reviews?
Never.
Have you ever.
That's why we're friends.
Have you ever,
have you ever blessed the comment on Youtube?
Nope.
That's why we're friends.
Have you ever hated on a guy on Instagram?
I don't think so.
No,
me neither.
not really.
My style.
No,
it's wasted time.
Yeah.
My friends don't do that.
I don't have any friends.
I don't get young.
Who the fuck you going to do is only so much time in this world?
You should use choose to use it wisely.
I was doing a mls,
showed some guy asked me question,
stood up and just,
hey man,
have you read the Youtube comments?
I went,
stop.
There he was.
I've never read a youtube comment on my lap.
My man,
so there's no quiet.
He goes,
really?
Never went.
Not once.
I'm too busy creating material for you guys.
I'm not reading comments,
man.
He's like,
oh,
alright.
No doubt.
He's trying to rights.
He's trying to tell you something he wrote,
so I'm sure she's really mean.
Probably probably trolling,
probably.
Maybe he felt that it was funny with it.
Hopefully not.
Um,
we're not hating on a garlic.
Johnny.
I love John.
Like I said,
there's,
there's no reason it is reality.
Right?
Okay.